joining me here uh loved seeing this guy
too and working with him
over the uh draft days in cleveland ohio
ian rappaport rap sheet back here on the
program how are you ian
i'm good um that was a fun week seeing
humans in person and doing real draft
stuff like you're
like right on the site you know like the
draft is
in cleveland we were also in cleveland
that was fun
it was indeed ian no doubt about it and
certainly since the way it all started
was that third overall pick and what the
niners are gonna do i do have kyle
shanahan
on an hour number three of the show to
hit him on that uh that got wiped out
because of what happened
uh and what became public about the
green bay packers and aaron rodgers
relationship
now or a few days removed aaron's been
to uh the kentucky derby and back where
do things stand right now as we're
talking the monday after the draft
yeah i mean i don't think enough is
being made of the fact that he literally
showed up at the derby looking like a
character from who framed robert roger
rabbit
um i think that needs i think someone
needs to delve into that we'll get into
them
the memes on the uh the memes on the
twitter were excellent
um but i guess the story was sort of all
the way down the road before that so
you know this is it is an issue being
fought on multiple fronts you have the
contract situation where
um you know aaron rodgers obviously
wants a new deal
wants the kind of deal where it would
ensure
that he is the packers quarterback for
beyond 2021 i think that is
that is a big part of the issue he
doesn't want to be replaced he wants to
be their starting quarterback
and when you draft jordan love and
obviously the
you know it's the way he was drafted is
something that i know frustrates rogers
that he didn't get a heads up but look i
mean anytime anyone
tries to replace you you get upset about
it so what he wants to do is make sure
he can't be replaced
so they've had long-term contract
extension talks it's obviously the
jordan love thing which we talked about
he wanted more say in personnel
decisions one thing i mentioned on
and if i'll never a couple minutes ago
was you know the release of jake kumaro
who you know obviously not a big name
but
that was one of rogers guys he praises
him publicly
at a press conference the next day the
personnel staff releases kumaro i mean
these are the sorts of things that drive
people crazy
um all of that went into the decision
so the decision which is what to to to
make it public
or to or or what like what the
decision to what to force the issue or
just
just to sort of try to separate himself
and you know this is something obviously
it's been going on for months
you know we've known and i mean mike
silver kind of
dictate uh reported some of this and you
know we've known for
a long time that rogers was upset you
know the decision to make it public
i'm not sure what went into that i mean
i can't you know you can't ignore the
fact that it was
made public right before one of the
biggest nights of the nfl season when
every network is
tuned into the draft i mean that's you
know that's all
that's all obvious it is what it is so
the decision about when to make it
public
you know those decisions were obviously
made by
i don't know not me um and you know
rogers comes out and said i wish it
hadn't become public i thought that was
interesting as well but anyway um this
is where we are and you know we'll see
if the packers can fix it because i
don't get the sense they're going to
trade them at all
well i don't think rogers is returning
unless things change
dramatically well here's the issue um
ian the ultimate
uh issue at heart here because i don't
believe any of this
stuff you hear elsewhere the buzz that
he wants gudekunst
fired or anything like that what he
wants is
as you say to be the quarterback beyond
2021
and what that means is a contract that
would
absolutely force the packers to keep
aaron rodgers
as the quarterback as well they should
normally
if they hadn't already drafted somebody
with the 26th overall pick last year
to eventually and groom his replacement
that there's no way that the packers
could
continue to go with that plan
and give the contract to rogers that
rogers
wants so he's not essentially saying get
rid of jordan love
but the contract that he wants does
although that's for darkness of jordan
love this would make it a little bit
easier but yes
well i mean obviously because the
wouldn't that be the only reason why the
packers
don't give the contract to rogers to let
him play till he's 40 because
he just won the mvp you know what i mean
it's not like that they're concerned
about diminishing returns the fact that
they don't give them that contract is
because they're still sticking to their
gotta look over the steering wheel guns
here right isn't that the ultimate
conundrum to this or am i off yes um
no you're not off um but i also think
um you know first of all the drafting of
jordan love you know rogers
hadn't nothing i mean he's always
obviously great but
they've been a small downturn in the way
he played out you know and if you're a
36 year old quarterback you don't play
great i think it's fair for a team to
say you know what let's prepare uh i
think part of the issue though
is the packers do contracts a certain
way and you know they give huge signing
bonuses with their deals
but they don't give multi-year
guarantees
um they just don't the bengals don't
packers don't the steelers don't just
the way they've
negotiated contracts for years um
and so they you know they really are an
organization that structures contracts
in a very disciplined way but
but doesn't lend itself to committing
long term to a guy
right so you know if they change their
contract structure and gave them a
you know fully guaranteed deal for the
next several years might that change
things
i think it might um but that's an
organizational decision and
you know certainly that's not something
that brian guticans would
um would be in charge of that's
something that goes much higher than him
you know all the way to mark murphy and
the rest of them so then let's just
before we move on last uh just
revisiting the details of what happened
last week
uh what was the manner of them visiting
him
here on the left coast and
did he really tell them you must trade
me
um because to me you know what can make
this all go away
is the right contract um and their
departure in
in or they could give him the contract
and pick up jordan loves
fifth year options sight unseen and hope
that it works out
you know what i mean like that could
that might be the way to get through it
as they keep jordan love there
and pay rogers anyway you know and then
and then and then when it's time to pick
up jordan love's fifth year option they
do that and deal with it
down the road that might be you know
a non-uh traditional way to handle it
but
what what did they do in malibu and and
and
did he really say i'm done to them to
their face
you know i haven't heard specifically
that he said you have to trade me
um i mean there's you know obviously he
was extremely
discontent and frustrated and upset
right i haven't heard officially that
it's you must trade me i think
you know i think the best for all sides
is the issue should be fixed and
yeah you know these are essentially
negotiations right i mean it's contract
negotiations it's um
input negotiations and we've seen this
from a lot of quarterbacks like how
about this rich
let's say last year instead of
kind of dancing around the tom brady
thing and you know
the patriots didn't make an official
offer and brady didn't tell them i want
to come and
you know by the time he went to robert
kraft's house he was kind of like yeah
let's just move on
let's say they said we're going to
commit to you for two years fully
guaranteed my guess is he'd still be in
new england
this is sort of what we do for aging
quarterbacks
um who still believe they are the guy
you know it's always the battle of they
want the fully guaranteed money
for as long as they play so you can move
on from them and the teams want the
flexibility
of hey if you start going the wrong way
we want to be able to move on
that is like the new battle now rogers
is not the first and he's not going to
be the last but that's why this is so
complicated ian rappaport here on the
rich eisen show
let's get into the deshaun watson of it
all because you know you and i were
talking after
i kind of went sort of um you know off
uh on a bit of a tangent when davis
mills got drafted saying what is
up with that so i'll just ask you a
question you know you did
so i i will ask you the question what is
up with that
the drafting of david so there's a
couple things here
right and i know uh everyone lost their
collective minds including my
um esteemed co-host not co-host but host
yes you know colleague or whatever you'd
say i elevated myself to host there by
the way all good
all good i can share um
so a lot of reasons there is uncertainty
around desean watson there is so much
that we don't know
like here are all the things we don't
know is he going to play for the houston
texans again
is he going to be on the field to start
2021
is he going to be suspended is there
going to be a criminal matter which is
going to move forward
in a way that will take him off the
field if they don't trade him
like he has requested would they
what would he do would he not show up
what would he do
uh are there teams who would give the
kind of compensation
to nick casiro that would make him
almost have to trade him
that's a lot of questions right and so
you have the houston texans you signed
like a thousand players in free agency
you plugged all the holes
all you had was a third round draft pick
and so what they decided was you know
what we're just gonna
we're just gonna take the best player we
can at the most important position
and maybe give ourselves some insurance
and if watson comes back and plays
fine if he doesn't we're prepared that's
the sort of way i look at it you know if
does it mean they're going to trade him
no does it mean he's going to be
suspended no
does it mean they're not going to trade
him no it means all of those things
which is why it was such a fascinating
pick and i'm glad that we spent the time
on the air sort of debating like we did
well i mean that's definitely a very
um reasonable uh take if the if you're
the texans
but to me after they don't at all
acknowledge the writing on the wall or
the sky riding in the air
to with so many holes use that
pick at the quarterback spot i mean like
if all things are equal it is truly the
last spot they need to upgrade
but clearly you are pointing out
nothing's equal
as a matter of fact it's thoroughly
unbalanced and the question
is is how how how to move forward
doesn't this
also admit that he's not coming back
again i know it's just a third round
pick
but third six round picks turn into
goats you know
so it is still a choice that's made for
an organization that's starting fresh
in the front office that has so many
holes to fill
uh that's why i'm like what what's going
on like isn't this an admission that
he's not coming back
period well i would also say the texans
do have a lot of holes to fill and
look with deshaun watson they would be
competitive this year without deshaun
watson i think we know which which way
the season is probably going to go
right so but here's the other so look
you take
you know take the best player you kind
of the most important position and
figure everything else out
but but here's the other part of it from
the general managers i spoke with
many of them do not believe this was a
great draft you saw
teams just
we saw some big trades big moves up with
like
fourth and fifth rounders this year the
kind of the likes of which we have not
seen
right like nick casperio another good
example traded a whole bunch of
late round picks for a receiver in i
think it was the fourth round whatever
it was mid-round receiver
um with the panthers where like
statistically the panthers really won
the trade by a lot
the patriots moved up big to take a
defensive tackle from alabama
same sort of thing there are questions
about whether or not those late round
picks would actually make your roster
just because the quality wasn't good
so if you're nicosia and you say all
right
i don't know if the you know cornerback
we take in the third round is going to
make our roster he may or may not the
quality is not good
i have no idea he's going to make our
roster but i know that the quarterback
is going to make my roster
that's sort of another way to explain it
because this was a draft i think people
don't think was great
overall so what's the general sense
you're hearing about
watson and his availability should
something happen because
you know i was pointing out before you
got you got teams with a ton of
capital in next year's draft that they
can easily use
on players next year and say that's what
we're planning to do all along
not like a mass just in case watson's
situation clears are you hearing
anything about
anything on that front well
here's here's where things stand teams
are still calling
nick casirio has not engaged in any
trade talks yet
right i have not gotten a sense uh
publicly that he will what he said
publicly has been very consistent
and you know to do these
to do these kinds of trades are insanely
complicated right watson needs to sign
off i mean
and we spent the whole offseason talking
about russell wilson what he'd be traded
and then it came down to it and he
wasn't and then john schneider goes yeah
we really didn't negotiate
you're like okay but that also explains
why these trades are so hard
because let's let's let's just assume
let's go to a different world
and let's say the text and say yeah
let's trade them well how much is worth
it how much is it worth it to say this
is going to be enough for us to find
another franchise quarterback who's as
good
as this guy is because he really is a
top five quarterback will someone really
give all the picks
um that's you know another question to
consider
and um you know that's another reason
why it didn't strike me that aaron
rodgers would get traded on draft night
just because the report came out you
know i mean these things can't just be
thrown together
in a span of about an hour and a half
when everybody's getting ready to do a
draft
like that that that was right
and how about how about this right the
packers i don't think could actually
even do it
i think he would have to renegot just
because of the cap hit right
i think he would have to renegotiate the
same reason we were talking about and i
felt like such an idiot
talking about the patriots you know
could they trade for jimmy garoppolo it
was an
option and then you actually look at it
and they physically
could not do it with the cap like they
were never going to with the salary it
was never going to happen
but they just physically they'd have to
cut other guys or restructure guys like
the money really talks in these
situations well he's still on the roster
we're all still alive and i'm talking to
kyle shanahan about all that in about uh
40 minutes so i'm looking forward to
that uh yes monday
yeah i definitely will uh
thank you for the call ian great job
this week truly appreciate it always do
whenever you're on this show and when we
whenever we get a chance to work
together thank you well
thank you rich you killed it as usual
thanks brother um and
maybe i'll see you in person again
sometime i hope so and enjoy your down
time you deserve it hopefully you get to
you get a chance to put the phone away
you got it that's rap sheet on twitter
instagram be part of the millions who
follow him his information is spot on
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here